his dad looks like a real prick it's
like Richard Nixon and Hitler combined
[Music]
thanks hey I didn't know you would
arrive hello Gareth welcome to my home
this is my car I'm starting to think you
might be a robot this is my cartoon
studio oh it's a studio now yeah sort of
in-house producing your own cartoon
that's right sure so mostly what I do
now is I'm watching a lot of old
cartoons to see how they work and then
from someone else makes these some from
that I'm taking ideas and but I like
friends to come by and I like to show
them maybe bat some ideas around I've no
interest look at moons we could make
this one is from 1930s called boy meets
dog it's actually a toothpaste
commercial seriously yeah yeah yeah
there's a toothpaste called the Ipana
toothpaste it was I upon a toothpaste
okay and they started 1901 and they were
really popular in like the 50s and then
I went away in the 70s gone forever
they were never approved by the American
Dental Association if you can believe
that why is that I don't know do we that
you don't know why they tell you it's a
great toothpaste okay okay so this is
some branded content for America's
popular toothpaste company that was
never approved by the Dental Association
that's right and it's called Boy Meets
dog you don't sound like you're on board
right now I mean I don't even know
what's happening anymore Jimmy roll it I
definitely know one thing there's not a
Jimmy
we've got a pube in frame see this seems
fun yeah comic strick regular fellas
which was a great comic strip I loved it
it was about regular fellas great
musical score mm-hm
here's an idea cartoons we don't need
credits
gorgeous yes I told you this is a nice
cartoon sometimes a man or some [ __ ]
feels like a Coen Brothers cartoon it's
beautiful animals butterflies a couple
of dudes fishing
oh the cocky fishing most things got for
set up everything that's my favorite
cake that kid has on acid did you see
[Music]
brushing your teeth huh so they got a
tooth school yep head down a old soda
fountain man three times yeah may you
know what I'd be doing in this soda
fountain place I bet the girls to split
a malt with me how did you miss that
there was a kid with a cape plus you're
on acid says dad won't let them do
anything now okay all my dad lets me do
is brush my teeth this is how you got
dogs back then well the first thing you
do expect the anus yeah yeah oh yeah you
could come out with me that's my
favorite thing when you take dogs and
they take a [ __ ] and then they start
kicking dirt all over it you're like I
don't need your help
his dad looks like a real prick - what
just off that yeah was he doing he's
putting a little it's gonna drown him
so boy it looks like a shaving cream of
a bike but it's dead I know I don't
understand bodies that are shaped like
that that's a lot of cartoon bodies
this absolute animal of yours yeah you
know it's like Richard Nixon and Hitler
combined it's Gargamel Jesus it's like
four we just saw the outside now sleep
in your bedroom of Horrors huge
staircase hi baby
got a Hitler mustache by the way yeah
that's what I'm saying this looks like
Nixon and Hitler combined nice triangle
life though this has been a killer this
is weird cuz he kills the Pete
oh my god yeah it's alright now we need
to eat him boys it's supposed to have a
magic eat the evidence boys drag him
into the wall painting this kid's gonna
have quite a time when he returns this
is a [ __ ] up house well we think that
the wallpaper murdered your father son
[Laughter]
oh they said guilty before he the trust
oh yeah in case anyone's wondering I'm
still gone man hey it's your favorite
baby Julie Ridgid on an all new baby
court where is the span from
stenographer it looks like he's coming
off a heroin yeah I really have a hard
time but if you're like on trial in this
courtroom you're like I did not like my
chances yeah this is
so the defense is doing their job he's
already been found guilty no but they're
saying he's a mental giant it's a dog
hope you don't know the dive it's not a
coincidence probably that there's big
mushrooms surrounding the scene yeah
yeah yeah had the dog in the world
[Music]
he sued a lot less authoritative not
good in the position of power [ __ ] up
jury this dad is like I'm dying for sure
[Music]
now let's make some mushroom tea they're
a little too excited I mean they must
have been waiting a long time for a
trial in the wall this guy by the way I
am so Pro having an organ in court oh
you mean someone playing the organ are
like a live eye in the in the corner of
the courtroom what did you know that was
coming
now I knew the kid looked like a baby
judge
so the kid just went into his wallpaper
and sentence his dad to go to hell to
become young again that's right and now
the grim reaper looks like a prospector
I think that's father time
oh by the way the way we youth you up is
just get out of you
well how else would you do it put him in
the beating room you know I see I really
like that one that one in his bottom get
that Hitler he'll be great if they left
them the only thing they leave
oh nice he's naked still with the
Hitler's - please the only thing I'm
asking is that we lose there we go
nope what was that thing doing I was a
dream oh I just had a life-ending fall
down the stairs
I forgot you forgot it was a commercial
with anyway um Berg um yeah yeah you
like firmer gums let me help out no no
don't touch me no you see you came
around
you know fish in never trust a guy who
made a quick u-turn like that
no anyway that's how you get someone to
lighten up I'm exhausted I'm exhausted
but I'm gonna start brushing my teeth
more boy that was insane yeah but that's
how that's how bass was back then it's
different now toothpaste yeah how'd you
guys like our toothpaste commercial
what it's a branded kata the toothpaste
commercial alright so then come across
when they went into the dwarf Court in
the walls you did me recognize that was
a bad gum firmness right
I actually don't brush my teeth for gum
firmness really are you I'm not willing
to have a conversation about the inner
workings of our mouths
[Music]